and the US Secretary of State has told
Congress at Hong Kong special status
with America should end as it's no
longer autonomous from China
it comes as Beijing prepares to impose a
new security law on Hong Kong which has
sparked more protests let's get more on
this with mr. Yin wrong he's a vice
president and senior research fellow at
the China Institute of International
Studies and joins me now from Beijing
good to have you with us sir on the
program thanks for your time how
concerned will Beijing be about any
report going to the US Congress and
dealing with Hong Kong's sort of
financial dealings with the USA well I
think the job this decision for
establishing and improving the legal
system and implementation and mechanism
of the national security outcome will be
adopted today at the National People's
Congress and the purpose for having that
job the decision is meant to address the
loopholes of national security
inch in security issues in Hong Kong and
it is as a central as a sovereign state
as in central government of China has
all the right like any other sovereign
state United States included that they
had the right to do that and they are
yet to do that I think I said it meant
to address look I'm going to jump in
there miss Rong because the question was
would Beijing care about what the u.s.
say or do with regards to taking this
matter to their own legislature to then
deal with Hong Kong and with China in
the status that they offer to Hong Kong
will Beijing actually be bothered about
that well China certainly hoped that
United States would understand the
reasons and the purposes do after
adopting a formulate in that decision
and that lesson
that is a legal system to ensure
national securities in Hong Kong and the
China also has made very clear the
central government and Hong Kong SAR
government very clear that it is not a
it is aimed at including national
security issues like the United States
and India and so any we only hope that
you understand that but of course and
that was made very clear China would
take all the necessary countermeasures
to respond anything I think that whether
undermine China's national security okay
if that's the case then sir will it
matter if for example financial
institutions veer away from Hong Kong if
the u.s. removes the status it offers to
Hong Kong or places indirect sanctions
on Hong Kong in a similar way do they
react in the way that they treat Iran it
succeeded to a certain point with Iran
and if the u.s. uses this methodology on
China how do you think Beijing is going
to react Hong Kong I think the stability
and prosperity of Hong Kong and the
status of international financial and as
sort of a center serve the interests or
certainly the interests of Hong Kong and
China and including in foreign investors
of there from other country including
United States I think it only hope that
the United States would not do that but
as you said that the United State has
been sanctioned for the various
sanctions on only other countries for
its own purpose and some on the
so-called national security and if you
look at these countries I think these
countries they live as it is so I don't
think the sanctions are saying whether
in a way that undermine China's in
determination and rather in the end I
think it would end up undermine its own
interest I mean including the idea the
United States building this community
interests in there it'll be interesting
to see what does happen certainly in the
coming weeks so the moment mr. Yin Ron
thanks so much for joining us from
Beijing so thanks for your time